[Music]
to take that shot basically at the
buzzer to win the game not many guys
make that shot luhan's is one of them
great five seconds summers bringing in
five seconds ago tie game seatbelts are
fastened Luke Williams for the win
goodness that just happened
move will become everybody in the gym
new blue whales was gonna shoot this
shot easily got it off in time and got
nothing but
but outside they were trying to get into
the hands of hooker but it's dead
Jake crossover with it raising up for
the shot and cashing in the mid-range
the veteran Jake crossover with eight
knocks it down goes right by Brogdon and
nails it play right there no time to
draw the foul he get he gets the basket
to go
Oh hold on you know what Ralph it is a
prayer but like lose those four Lou
always go in so it's like it's a prayer
for everybody except for him just knows
how to find the rim off balance
defenders on them won't get us to do
let's forget that
so you'll see what's happening there now
you got a 20
[Applause]
[Music]
Hey
it is Jim Crawford donate $100 to some
charities on the dropper tree or to
close the game inside the 2-minute mark
any overtime
that's just an amazing job he is
unbelievable Ralph McKinney's
fallen-down he runs into him but Josh
Jackson possibly could some are longer
threads the needle the 8nu goes to the
tenth floor and foul chance at a
three-point slate like eighty times have
we seen this from the ball where he
passes the ball in a crowd experience in
anybody reset to 14 nowadays Williams
defended by Forbes
[Applause]
29 feet away and he gives his team the
lead 40 seconds to go mom would even saw
last five seconds of Shaq block Crawford
rising up and knocking it down and we
have a foul at the end of the play it's
all out of whack that's separate this
cleared out I don't know if they kept
track of this with them once it go to
his left
Donald ball fake back to Luke one Papa
got a lock on to 20 for Lou Williams Lou
Williams going left just look at the
pity Peck that ball was thrown back to
get us out that settle three or two Oh
Mark Davis was in official indicators it
was a tube
his foot was on the line Ralph the to
what was on the line his right foot was
on the line
[Music]
he said you Crawford raising up with
terrific yes indeed for jig crossover to
a big finish to the period for the
Lakers two seconds to go Luke Williams
from midcourt momentum swings one way
and just that quickly it swings back the
other way
Wow didn't leave his hand before the red
lights around the board come up one more
time we watch oh yes that baskets good
Wow
especially on the angel yeah unless
you're a true master at it is Crawford
of those long arms able to generate the
steal and how about that little sidestep
move by TJ Warren passed the rookie here
in the first tab Robert with his deal
and
rush hour to the rim Wooper is led by
eight at 90 to 84 where'd that happen
three ball by Lou Williams third quarter
the sons were ice-cold they shot this
36% Crawford working against Parker and
a classic Crawford fashion splashing
through the twine as the shot clock
expired Chung Mardan
[Applause]
Lou Williams go up and get it
send this crowd knocks one down it's a
three-point game a two-point game
had it poked away you've got to be so
cautious with Jack Harrison big shot
new checks the clock like what he saw on
Brando he's three for three from long
range Crawford looking for the triple
and he will get it proud to own the
three-point zone Fulton homes donates
$100 to such charities if he should be
considered but you see the nice screen
by agent just enough to open up here
comes little William fine boy that's
right William his three-point shooter
today proffered try to make it three
straight and yes he does
Mavericks on top Clippers final
possession now three seconds to go Lou
Williams gliding left firing right at
the hip it's a two parter
grab the break by a score of 35 the 34
we the Jake crossover offers leans back
[Applause]
and Jamal Crawford this is we suspect it
goes to work late and Williams is going
to be able to go off these screen and
rolls you try to get easy shot or three
bang Lou Williams was down the three
ball - the holes have to get them
Robert working off the home screen sets
up Crawford for the three wild insert
basketball kept alive by the Clippers in
making you commit and drawing the foul
as soon as he field contact serves to
have the lead and the ball here play
clever journaling always bouncing with
the ball and just seen that a million
times just stops he's got such a good
feel feels that little bump from behind
takes his time he is the master to the
hole Barea want to tuck his players in
the league even though he's the shortest
player what a bus transplant
[Applause]
the phone said it earlier when it comes
to get into the line and get in contact
floor as any which he considered true
point guard in the NBA
pretty good defender as well up ahead to
Warren and Warren despite two defenders
he seen which surround him gets it up
with it
lose the floor against her up go for
three bang go low Williams Wow
the big three ball to eat them things up
put 36 drop is going to work against
Noel again with the step back and that
is tough defense but some Jake crossover
Oh Beverly out the sweet move to rookie
you're gonna get that call but Lou
Williams hands down your pants down Lou
Williams have you forgot what was
brother like the sun's and the arena and
the city to educate the fans is Crawford
with a much needed bucket for the son
property gets that one to go speaking of
offense I always talk about the
pre-draft guys that I had Ralph Paton
was one of the whole
easy game we do it that way Terry rips
away another rebound tuple one shot here
from Crawford who raised it in from deep
blue Williams in for shade guilds a
solid center for the Clippers down long
stroll catching tossed into the goal by
montrezl harrell at red arrow and you
see this early little good pass to my
trans on the money so the Clippers are
team that have the speed advantage
athleticism and they've got to go faster
often they're gonna have success tonight
terrific straight up defense day for the
rookie McHale bridges
[Applause]
you can't tell Patrick family who the
who the big man is in that situation
William / go bear go get it big fella go
get it
we're back maybe you could slow this
against Paul and rolling down the lane
takes it pretty feet from propert for
the two-hand slam smack him down
balls nah close for defense on to the
sides alive full of old strength and
explosiveness just elevating quickly
down the beasts in Jabari Parker
sometimes you know Louie just finished
with a regular layer but he don't see
the double-team attention shot clock
winding down
Crawford launching the three at down it
goes Oh it's not a noted defensive teams
have done pretty darn good job at it
[Applause]
these young guys can't start to fall
apart been buried letting Lou Williams
get to his left hand Lou's saying look
Matt I don't care how many times I've
been wants to gain you think it was
close and there's more so that the
thrill Blazers Vince got outplayed by
the sons and this continuum property
under dollars for some charities docpods
down to five smothering defense on
Daniels here's Crawford just turned 39
years of age yesterday but he could
still fill it up for the top blue
William let it fly in desperation in the
head that's making something but nothing
folks signed on with the Wizards back
early September is eight
takes a soft beat up top right here
that's just Jamal Crawford is really
getting the tips runs out of room
Carroll has that distance not this
couple tone out there
loo will fire the plate bang go Lou
Williams timeout is called sweet Lou is
doing hit Crawford raising up where the
threes is
I'm a little inspired from the rookie
Bridges who got two of those in the
opening quarter in those plays back of
the line contested shots down to seven
again there's the steal daunting to the
turnover real slam at home with the
right hand
this might be done be a record of - slam
dunks Robert again on the pulpit on the
front of the three-point play
lowly's is creeping it's then he said
okay I got free-throw shooting down this
year down to 65% a career 80% really
weird little Williams from the corner
that man Julius Randle people are than
Willie invited know that eight points
with J crossover Peppers come up with
him two for one opportunity
lose aware of it fires it Ringo
as he is improved as a shooter around
30% is property Beatty Clark go to the
reach-in 30 minutes
good move there put on the brakes play
the way back touched him on the elbow
that's an automatic file the Clippers to
push this lead out to double figures
Williams for the night 89 through the
year
you see gotcha we see that at least once
a night don't we
that'll be 41 admit you
[Music]
shot clock winding down then was gonna
have to shoot it shoots a three over
Durant but senedd as the shot clock
expires
32:24 here in this third quarter
thanks in large part to this guy and
he'll add two more a chance to make it
Greek Hussey Essington Oilers fellowship
31 at 11 in his postseason players June
and he really is
yeah the age of 39
he was going to look to head
is already will make briefer look at
this and the bow
by the bull needs to be in his hand
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content